we've gotten away from using the term
[ __ ] as an insult or in casual
language in modern American society
because it's not good for people who
actually suffer from Down syndrome it's
not good for their families and their
friends it's not good to use that term
about people with other cognitive and
intellectual limitations but this
apparently hasn't stopped the Iranian
president from seemingly seriously
claiming that Donald Trump suffers from
mental retardation this was during a
live televised address at least
partially commenting on the new US
sanctions against Iran the president
Donald Trump has announced Donald Trump
of course imposing these new sanctions
on Iran the Iranian president Hassan
rouhani calling the sanctions outrageous
and idiotic and adding that quote the
White House is afflicted by mental
retardation and does not know what to do
as translated and reported by The
Associated Press from the native Farsi
there are other translations that are a
little bit softer suggesting that the
terms cognitive limitations are
something along those lines were
actually what was used a disagreement
about exactly how it should be
translated from Farsi now almost as
importantly but maybe not quite
pragmatically the Iranian president also
saying quote you sanctioned the foreign
minister simultaneously with a request
for talks and this goes to the erratic
and sort of a very strange nature of
what Donald Trump has been doing with
regard to Iran that I talked about in
the first segment at which we discussed
the undeniable reality that in the end
when you put the bluster and the
rhetoric aside Donald Trump's actual
actions are going mostly in line with
what a Vladimir Putin with Russia as the
top priority would want Donald Trump to
do a four years ago I had told you that
in 2019 world leaders would be calling
each other
Rocketman and mentally [ __ ] I
wouldn't have believed it maybe some in
our audience would but here we are in
2019 and there's this hilarious double
standard among trumpets who all of a
sudden now are pretending that mentally
[ __ ] is outside the line
and an inappropriate way to talk about
Donald Trump when they've spent the last
almost four years calling anyone that
disagrees with them a [ __ ] world
politics under Obama let's generate
productive dialogue for the mutual
betterment of all humans on earth world
politics under Trump who is the biggest
[ __ ] or cuck or low energy person and
truly to take this seriously for a
second because it is serious people with
Down's syndrome often care about others
and express significant empathy Donald
Trump actually seems to be completely
lacking that like aside from this being
meant as an apparent insult most people
with intellectual disabilities seem to
be better people than Donald Trump who
exhibits cruelty his bullying nature
greediness complete self-absorption in
every way and Trump meanwhile responding
that Iran the Iranian president's mom is
gay or something like that I'm kidding
but seriously Trump is actually unstable
enough that calling him mentally
[ __ ] could actually trigger a war it
could actually trigger military action
remember that Donald Trump just a few
days ago approved the strike on Iran
without even considering civilian
casualties later he was told what they
would be I believe about a hundred and
fifty and then he canceled the attack or
at least he claims that's the reason why
this has the potential to completely
derail Trump and meanwhile the Trump
administration is still preaching it has
leverage around the Iran deal which
Trump backed out of John Bolton Donald
Trump's national security adviser again
is saying all options remain on the
table with Iran if they exceed the
uranium enrichment limit that is put in
place by the 2015 Iran nuclear deal
Trump pulled us out of the deal the
United States has no authority to
enforce that deal because Trump pulled
us out of it you can have the discussion
and we have had it already by the way
you can argue there are still other
signatories to the Iran nuclear deal
that have not backed out the UK Germany
our European allies and maybe you could
say they have the leverage to enforce or
demand the enforcement of that deal
although the United States has made it
quite difficult for them
actually do that the United States has
given away all credibility and leverage
to demand adhering to that deal given
that we pulled out of it and it is
absolutely pathetic that even on
corporate media some Trumpf lackeys
flunkies flax flax or flunkies Blackie's
I think that's going to be another Urban
Dictionary term Trump flunkies are being
allowed to say this that hey Iran still
has to stick to that deal that's going
to be up to our allies to decide whether
they want to or can't even enforce that
after the United States has departed
from the deal no one in the Trump
administration should even be mentioning
the requirements of the Iran deal
because we are no longer part of that
deal if you disagree with me let me know
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show